as it is a little after 10 o'clock I'd
like to open the subcommittee work
session on House Bill
113 relative to physical fitness
performance requirements for law
enforcement offices at this time please
thank you everyone for coming today to
speak about this bill I was a little
afraid when I woke up this morning and
tell him and I start about three inches
of snow on the ground I wanted to sleep
in a little bit and I was hustling to
get here so what I'd like to do now is
it's going to be very informal uh we're
going to have everyone just come up here
and speak casually uh members of the
committee want to to talk about it
certainly and I know that representative
Muse has a couple things that he like to
present I'd like to call the uh sponsor
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Michael Abbott and
um I'm a representative of Cheshire six
which includes the towns of Chesterfield
Hinsdale and Westmoreland
my whole
reason for sponsoring
this uh
bill
is because the difficulty the
communities like those that I represent
have difficulty in recruiting and
retaining police officers
because
for some of them
and that this physical fitness
um
can be a real challenge for people
especially as they age such as myself
not that I would be interested in being
a police officer or but I am interested
in retaining police officers and those
police officers who like to live in a
and as I said I think when my testimony
on this bill that even though it might
be as physically grueling
for
a firefighter
to perform his duties it's
there is no
requirement for periodic physical
fitness test for
environment and I think in a small
community like those that I represent
who rely on a volunteer fire department
this would be a disastrous
and I think that the same requirement
should be done
for the safety
element
for people to feel safe
and being protected in the communities
which they serve
and oftentimes uh just in
my locale
than police officers will go
to
surrounding cities such as Keene
or Greenfield Massachusetts or
Brattleboro Vermont
where they're going to be much
compensated much better than a community
the communities that I represent
kind of could afford to pay
that's really the old gist of why I
sponsored
are there any questions of the
representative
I know I was the first uh Academy class
that went through with the physical
fitness requirement uh
I do agree that there's a lot of
retention issues and I know what there
was back in 2001 when I was hired and
it's even gotten worse so I do agree
that that could be the issue here that
officers are going where they're going
to get compensated and not have to worry
about a physical fitness exam my only
problem is if we completely get rid of
it at that
the public might look negatively upon
that that we've had this law for 20
something years and why do we just get
rid of it I know that representative
Muse has a proposal uh I believe
representative you did you have a chance
to read that over yes yes I did okay uh
at this time representative Muse would
you like to discuss that and see if
you're
amenable to this
what what uh what my proposal uh that's
not an amendment uh would do or not an
amendment yet um would actually do is
instead of repealing
um uh sections uh nine and ten as your
bill would do what it would do is it
would leave them in place
but what it would do is it would provide
it would provide more a lot more
flexibility in the process so what it
would do is it would actually give
officers an additional option of
demonstrating uh evidence of annual
participation in a wellness program
administered by either the Hiring Agency
or by the council
so
um instead of the instead of passing the
fitness requirement being mandatory
there would be an alternative
where an officer could participate in a
wellness program each year
and taking a look at the information
that's on the U.S Department of Justice
website one of the things that um that
they've done is just a great job of
organizing uh uh and and really giving
the public access to uh an incredible
amount of useful information about how
various departments and agencies across
the country have designed these programs
and I think one of the things having
done Wellness communication for large
corporations I know that that's a very
individualized thing uh you know and and
I think uh it's very important that that
people who understand
the issues are developing uh you know
developing a program
so I think it's important that um the
legislature kind of keep its hands off
in terms of micromanaging exactly what
the program what would be required as
part of the program
and leave it up to the agencies leave it
up to the police
standard standards and training Council
to actually develop a program that could
be more focused not only on issues like
physical wellness but also mental
well-being
I know that there there is an officer
suicide issue that we have we've had in
New Hampshire and and we also have in
other parts of the country
PTSD can also be be a big issue so the
idea would be to provide more
flexibility in the process
and and really give more flexibility to
officers
in terms of how they want to what they
think they need to do to kind of keep
their own Wellness up to speed the the
one thing I would say is is section 10
um there there could be a case where
because most Wellness programs are
voluntary and and one thing I can tell
you about my own experience is that
mandatory Wellness programs aren't a
great idea it's best to have voluntary
participation but you may have officers
who not only fail the test but who don't
uh uh who who also for one reason or
another don't elect to participate in
the wellness program
um and if an officer like that fails the
test they would be the only ones that
would actually be that that uh
potential
suspension could apply to
um it's it's literally an officer who
doesn't want to do anything uh in in
this area but what it what it would do
is for an officer that had
um let's say a physical issue recovering
from surgery there would be options uh
for them to complete the requirement and
stay in the good graces of their
department and the council that don't
involve having to run a 1.5 mile race at
the age of 59 or however old they are
um so that that's my idea
provide more flexibility in the process
and allow uh allow the the council and
individual departments if they want to
representative yukida comment
yes I think that
it sounds like
a very good idea and I just my biggest
problem is
as you pointed out representative is
this this qualification uh criteria of
how having to run a mile and a half
um to me it just doesn't seem to be
reasonable I've I someone might make the
point well in order to run a mile and a
half in Under 12 minutes or whatever the
time is what a person would have to be
in good physical shape but I don't think
that is a reasonable
requirement in terms of what their
everyday job is
I can concur representative uh
some are able to run marathons but they
can't do a sit-up or push-up to save
their life some can do a hundred sit-ups
and 100 push-ups
uh I just think that what representative
Muse was saying is we we can tweak this
so it's just not those three sit-ups
push-ups mile and a half it might be
something else to show that you are in
shape and physically fit and that
doesn't have to be that those three uh
criteria
um
do you have anything else you get a
comment representative
no I've I've taken enough of your time
thank you if I could call up the uh
members of the police standards and
training
uh good morning Mr chairman good morning
folks I appreciate your time for the
record John skippa director of police
standards and training and with me is
Captain Adam Hawkins who is the bureau
chief for uh professional development
and online learning uh who all Saul
the goal is shared by everyone in the
room
and that is from our perspective
uh the overall Wellness of the officer
is our goal that's really what we're
trying to establish and trying to help
maintain throughout that officer's
career
uh I'll go as far as to say that uh
representative Muse uh in my opinion did
an excellent job of of providing that
summary of really what we're aiming at
which is the the the totality of
Wellness not only from the physical
point of view but also from a mental
health point of view uh candidly we need
to fit in financial Wellness as as part
of that uh training program there's a
lot of young police officers that get
into the business and they don't know
how to balance a checkbook or plan for
the future those are those are all
things that are vitally important uh
that we see as an opportunity to help
as it stands right now the tests that we
require police officers to take the
fitness tests
are tied directly to their certification
it is very much a regulatory function
this fitness test was established 23
years ago and
um and and the relationship is between
the individual officer and police
standards and training who issue that
license to them
and so the council's position right now
and and as it was uh 23 years ago was
that police officers in the state of New
Hampshire have to maintain a level of
fitness
as part of uh their ability to
my opinion is that
the present test that we use
for the regulatory function of measuring
whether a person is able to meet the
physical demands of being a police
officer
is probably not the best test to use
that is really
that is my opinion and I don't want to
speak for the captain but I believe the
captain would agree that there's
alternative testing out there that
really is a much uh much more in line
with what we're trying to accomplish
the sad truth is that it's difficult to
create
uh situations to measure functional
capacity
when one of those things that you're
trying to measure is an officer's
ability to be able to be in a physical
altercation for a minute
it's very difficult to
recreate that in a safe way
and so uh in the past and as it stands
right now the reason that that officer
runs a mile and a half is to demonstrate
that they have the cardiovascular
capacity
to stay
in a protracted physical altercation
it's kind of we're kind of doing a
little translation that if they can run
that mile and a half and that amount of
time then they should be able to uh
defend themselves and stay safe if
they're attacked
again
we're using a little translation right
between those two events
it is it is our opinion that we we
probably need to look at a more
functional
test that mirrors those things that a
police officer will have to do
regardless of whether they're 20 or 40
or 60 whether they're a man or a woman
or candidly transgender we're not what
we want to do is create a test that is a
single test for the position of a law
enforcement officer period
uh
we have a subcommittee that we are
working on with members of the New
Hampshire Chiefs Association
with regard to exploring alternatives to
I would say that really
the thing that is in front of us
uh I guess from our perspective my
do we have
enough support
to look at using a different test
or does the legislature feel that we
need to just do away with the test
because remember it's regulatory in
nature
and uh looking at the proposal this
morning uh absolutely uh this would be a
way to go about doing it
but I don't think it would need to be
captured in law I think really what
would happen is if the uh
if the bill were to just go forward and
that physical fitness test be removed
the alternative would be that we would
we would try to create
an overall wellness program
uh as kind of a voluntary thing to push
out to all the agencies across the state
and the states would have their excuse
me the towns and cities would have their
own opportunity to build their own test
as well in their own wellness program
so I don't know that it would need to be
captured in statute
I do look at the proposal under Roman
numeral 10
where there's an officer that maybe
could not pass their
their test in a three-year period and
they get six-month extensions up to the
five-year Mark where they have to pass
it
um
the way I'm reading 10 and I may I may
not be understanding it but it
it certainly allows somebody to just not
have to pass any test as long as they're
participating in some type of wellness
program
uh
I do agree with the the notion that we
have to use the carrot and not the stick
right that's our goal is to make sure
that these folks stay healthy
uh
but I do think that the the
proposed legislation under house bill
113 right now is just asking
do we want to leave this as part of the
regulatory function and mandate every
police officer to pass a test whatever
that test might be
or
do we just want to get rid of it and
allow people and agencies to create
their own Standalone program for their
agency in their town
uh anecdotally uh this uh topic and this
bill
is of national interest right now and I
don't know if anybody here in this
subcommittee knows that or not but
um this uh is a a very hot topic Across
the Nation
and uh there's a lot of people watching
whether New Hampshire is going to get
rid of this three-year test
and there's a lot of people who are
saying that we should not get rid of the
test we should not get rid of it
now I'm sure a lot of those people who
are writing that we shouldn't get rid of
it didn't have to take a three-year test
when they were working you know out on
the West Coast or in the in the central
part of our country nonetheless
um
it is my firm belief that working with
the Chiefs and with New Hampshire Police
Association I think they should be at
the table and the sheriff's Association
I think if we were given the opportunity
to revisit what we're using for testing
and uh
trying to find something that is going
to be more functionally uh related to
the job of a police officer creating a
single cut test with a single number
uh may I think that's the way that we
should probably look at this
alternatively
uh
I would say that if
if the legislature's belief was that now
we really don't want to worry about uh
police officers or Corrections Officers
they should kind of be responsible for
themselves or their agency should be
responsible then you know certainly uh
House Bill 113 as written right now
would if it were to pass it would that
would create that kind of opportunity
for local control
and it would be one less regulatory
function that we would have to to look
over I think from a regulatory point of
view this proposal would probably
be much more I not probably it would be
more difficult for us to manage from
from a regulatory point of view I think
this would be a very difficult thing for
us to kind of keep track of
um
I don't know if anyone has any questions
or Captain if you wanted to offer
represent him slow thank you
uh director if this bill was to pass do
you think some pandemonium would ensue
in the law enforcement community in New
Hampshire
I think that there would be
um
when you say pandemonium among the
police or or among the among the among
the police I'm sorry among the police
that this affects so I there's going to
be a lot of people If This Were to pass
and we got rid of this three-year
testing I think there are some police
officers that would be very happy to see
that go away uh because then they would
not be held to any kind of uh oversight
with regard to them maintaining some
level of Fitness they would be very
happy about that and they would
uh not have to worry about passing a
test they would not have to worry about
working out they would not have to be
worried about taking care of themselves
uh
so I I think there'd be a group that
would be very happy about that I think
that there would be a group of police
officers that would be very disappointed
because because we're the only state in
the country that does this
there are some unmeasured benefits to
this program in that the police officers
that work in New Hampshire right now we
know you have to pass this test every
three years I'll even stretch it out
every five years you've got to pass this
test
and I think there's a lot of bosses out
there that um would be really
disappointed to see this go
notwithstanding uh not so much with
recruitment but certainly retention
recruitment is recruitment they're going
to have to take a fitness test to come
to the academy anyway so that that has
no balance a separate element uh but
retention
that may that may have some play May
maybe
um we again it's difficult to measure
how many people we lose annually because
they can't pass the test because a lot
of it is mirrored as uh just a normal
retirement the officer has has made
their time
and they have decided not to stay and so
they retire we don't know why they
didn't stay
follow up on that
how many decertifications occur annually
for the sole purpose of not being able
to complete a PT test at the three or
thank you for that question so we've
been talking about a lot of what-ifs how
many people have left
my position as Captain
um is to look at the data since coming
to the academy I'm going to
self-deprecate a little bit I might look
like I'm coming out of college but I've
been in law enforcement this is my 20th
year
so coming to the academy in 2018
Wellness physical fitness was all was
obviously a priority of mine and we've
been talking about uh changing or
enhancing this test for a while
specifically when it comes to running
professional development
I deal specifically with every aspect of
physical fitness testing in the state so
that's people who are doing their
three-year PT tests I've helped officers
train to come to the academy I've helped
officers come back from injury I speak
with people who are let's say in a
probationary status or people who have
gone over their five-year and and are
looking for help to get or pass their
test to get back on the job so we've
talked about how many people have left
when it comes to the three-year pts
coming up but I can specifically speak
to the data because we have a training
management learning management system
that we use to record that data so over
the past I would say about three years
we've had 3 892 tests
that we that we can point to
we have about
801 grandfathered officers in the state
who don't actually actually have to take
the test so actually looking at the
tests with the people who are actually
taking the test
um it's about 90 100 tests that I could
look at in the past three years of those
tests
94.6 percent of them passed the three
year test we have about
about five percent who's in a
probationary or a medical status
but in terms of the question that you're
asking about how many people that we can
just point to uh data about 15 officers
over the past uh three years have not
passed their tests and have been
suspended so that's about less than a
half half percent of officers who try to
take this test go into that suspension
status
clarifying question yep that includes
part-time and full-time that's all
certified officers in the state of New
Hampshire so Corrections part-time
full-time
yes represent Gathering
um
the the running tests for it can you
tell me what's the minutes or when they
do that run half a one and a half mile
run
so the oh I'm sorry in how many minutes
are up
shower yeah so
I wish it was a half I was gonna say I'm
with you
[Laughter]
uh so it is dependent on your age and
it's dependent on your gender
so uh a 20 year old male will have to
run their test their their mile and a
half and uh what is it 1256 is it
1253 12 minutes and 53 seconds
as a 60 year old man I
uh I would have an extra five minutes to
run my mile and a half and in both cases
uh
it's considered a pass
so I think if you I think this is a
great example Madam where
um
the Cooper test that we use right now we
are asking people to demonstrate how
healthy they are
as compared
to
people who are in the same age bracket
and the same gender
so when we have a 25 year old male we're
asking them to be physically fit
uh to a degree that that they're at
least 35 percent more physically fit
than people who are 20 to 29 years of
if we have a 45 year old female
incumbent officer
presently the Cooper standards require
them to demonstrate a level of Fitness
where they are at least
35 percent
more fit
than women between the ages of 40 and
yes
today
you can go to Captain you know
makes the rules as to what the officer
has to do
so in in my opinion when I look at this
we're not telling you how to do your
training that's up to you we're just
saying you have to do certain trainings
so for me I really don't even understand
why we really have this bill I'm trying
to figure it out
um because you can decide how you want
your training to be anyway without us
so why would we remove this I think
we're just saying that you have to have
a certain types of training and I like
representative Muse idea that it doesn't
necessarily have to be a physical
training
you know
how you present these training is up to
you
we're not specific as to that that's
what you do you make the specificate of
the training not us
so
I am
still like this
I think uh representative gaththright I
understand what you're saying like how
are you going to train to get that mile
and a half whether you run or you
bicycle or your swim but it's you still
have to meet that specific requirement
whether you
uh for push-ups I don't know you're
juggling Stones uh just throwing stuff
out there yeah but it's not like set up
on how you have to pass it it's just
that you have to pass it at that
particular right but the determination
as to passing comes from the trainers
for the developers of the training
it doesn't come from US
Representative Stone first sorry uh I
think some confusions coming in between
wellness and physical fitness standards
most agencies that I'm aware of I think
still do both they're two separate
issues and usually most agencies handle
the wellness is kind of more like a I
don't know it's more like an insurance
thing through their you know primex or
whoever their carrier is so most
agencies do have the wellness program
built in and it serves for a specific
differences between the physical fitness
that you're measuring for proficiency
than just a well wellness program
so most agencies I believe I would say
in New Hampshire by this time must have
you know some option of a wellness
program that's optional usually that's
included but the regulatory standard is
that an individual officer has to pass
the physical fitness test
every three years then you have graduate
waivers for what you said up to five
years currently
so I think that's what we're really
looking at and they're looking at is
that
is it
cumbersome is it prohibitive to have the
three years
to do pt when it comes to recruitment
for out-of-state officers that want to
come here for a job I know that's one of
the things I think I heard during
testimony for the original bill when it
was presented
um additionally
there's nothing that I am aware of and
you could speak to this director or
Captain that doesn't an agency could
have their own standards they establish
that's higher than what the state
requires is that is that correct thank
you for that question that's absolutely
correct we uh we set minimum standards
the New Hampshire police centers and
training Council actually sets these
standards and uh statutorily as it
stands right now the council has that
statutory authority to establish
whatever fitness test the council feels
is most appropriate but agencies can set
the bar higher uh there are agencies
that set higher physical fitness
standards and they say hey if you want
to work here you have to be able to do
even more push-ups and sit-ups than pstc
asks for
um
with regard to
whether agencies have Wellness programs
or not we can't speak that we don't know
uh and it would be presumptive
for me to say that a majority of them do
I I don't know uh
just for a follow-up yes so with an
example still be the New Hampshire State
Police that require a higher uh Fitness
standard than the regular locals coming
in or Municipal coming in through the
academy for the basic trading if they
have a higher standard which would not
surprise me I'm not aware of it but they
certainly can set that bar higher if
they choose to the same thing with a
pistol qualification quite frankly
there's some agencies that hold their
officers to a higher uh pistol
qualification then what we would from a
regulatory point of view
so let's say just as an example the New
Hampshire State Police have a higher
Fitness standard and that Trooper
doesn't pass it and I I don't know this
we're using this just as an example then
that Trooper might be dismissed from you
know employment situation but they
haven't lost their certification because
they can still pass it at at our state
level requirements right
so that's more of an employment
relationship than a certification
relationship thank you
uh just a comment on that when I was
hired with the state police back in 0-1
it actually was the same as the Lawrence
now I don't know in the time since I've
left that it's higher but I know it was
at least the minimum that the academy
had uh representative Manion and then
representative Muse
thank you Mr chair
um and correct me if I'm wrong uh
representative the gas right but I want
to try to answer or at least explain her
question how I understood it
there's a law that was put in place 23
years ago requiring the academy to
uh conduct this sort of this training
every three years and she's wondering if
you if you're in charge of regulating
the training and this law disappears
can't you just hold that test every
three years anyways or is it as a result
of the current law that says you have to
she's wondering if we get rid of this
bill does that change anything of this
law so I didn't am I wrong and yeah and
what you're trying to ask
so the per what's the purpose of us
being here repealing this flaw if you
could just make that
that standard every three years as a
regulatory decision
only because it's captured it's
presently captured in 106 L uh
six I believe
uh uh no uh
it's uh eight nine and ten I believe
eight nine and ten
uh
presently as as statutorily
under 106
the council has
the uh the ability to
create a fitness test
and we use that as and
I'm hearing the word training and
testing and those are two different
things
testing is what we're talking about here
so
right now statutorily
police station training Council
has a
physical test
that needs to be passed every three
years by every police officer law
enforcement officer in the state of New
Hampshire in order for them to maintain
their certification
whatever that test is
can be decided by the council
so the council has the authority to
switch the test from the Cooper
standards which is what we're using now
to a different test
and that's what we're this subcommittee
with the New Hampshire Chiefs that's
what we're trying to figure out is
what is an alternative test that we can
use
that is more functional
and and
uh maybe a little bit
I hate to use the word easier but it
just makes more sense to switch to a
more functional test than the present
test that we are using
If This Were to go away
then there would be no Fitness
requirement for police officers from our
regulatory point of view we would not be
doing Fitness testing as part of those
officers maintaining their certification
their license I don't know if that I
think that answers the question okay so
if the bill is repealed
you would not require that even though
you have regulatory Authority you would
not require a three-year
fitness test to maintain certification
if hb113 were to to pass that that is
correct thank you
director is there a timetable on that
for the the subcommittee getting
something workable uh there's thank you
for that question there's no specific
timetable we knew uh when this bill was
first introduced uh there was a lot of
discussion at New Hampshire Chiefs
meeting I don't want to speak for their
organization
but I do know that they saw that this
was such an important bill that they
created a subcommittee uh and invited uh
myself and the captain to participate in
to try to find an alternative test or or
to
decide whether uh the three-year testing
needs to be repealed or whether it
should be held and and again I don't
want to speak for that organization but
I do know that there was uh a there was
vigorous discussion and uh there was a
lot of points of view and I think that's
part of what that uh that subcommittee
is working on right now thank you
so as legislators we have a bunch of
choices right now
um one of the things we could do is is
we could itl the bill
um and then put forward a different bill
in the fall
um more along the lines of something
that might Garner more support within
police because it seems like right now
police are pretty divided on this as
well which is one of the reasons why I
think why the Chiefs didn't take a
position on this
um another thing that we could do
um and it would require
uh probably uh a fair amount of effort
on your part but accelerate that
timetable so one of the options that's
available to the committee is to retain
this bill
um I would recommend that the chair
retain the bill we can't retain the bill
um and uh and work on it over the summer
and over the summer one of the things
that we could do is get an update from
from you on the status of what the
subcommittee is coming up with is there
does that proposal address at least some
of the concerns you know that have been
brought brought forward uh brought
forward to the committee
um and and I guess maybe to uh
you know I I think uh representative
tenzar asked a uh probably the most
pertinent question of the moment which
is how far along is the subcommittee uh
because I think that will have a lot to
do I know with with what I just what I
decide
representative Stone
thank you director I know you've been
around for a few minutes can you
remember how long the Cooper standard
has been utilized at the New Hampshire
State Police Academy
I do uh thank you for that question I
was a uh
I look like him 23 years ago and uh my
job uh at the police academy as a
training specialist was to roll this
program out so we roll I rolled the
program out Statewide it went into
effect uh January 1st 2001 and so uh
probably a year before that I started to
create a bunch of training material a
training class to roll out to New
Hampshire and and then get uh
folks certified to be able to run the
test at their agency
just clarification but the Cooper
standards have been used at the police
academy predate that correct
uh
yes
so I would say as not a three-year test
so for yourself but just general Cooper
standards that's utilized by the police
academy for recruitment so to to uh
provide that answer I will tell you when
I went to the police academy in 1989
there was no Cooper standards we had a a
a number of tests a mile and a half run
a shuttle run a dummy drag push-up
sit-ups I can't tell you where any of
those Target numbers came from
when I was a training specialist from uh
1991 to 2000 and
no uh 1998 to 2003
we use Cooper standards for Fitness
testing for recruits
so it was there
at least 1998
thank you thank you
representative
I went through in 1995 but I am 99 sure
use Cooper then as well could be wrong
thank you I appreciate that was uh that
was nice yes I did not look like him 23
years
I'm actually 25 and this is what I look
like
uh is there anyone else that cares to
speak upon uh director do you have
anything else you'd like to add to this
excellent testimony
no I I appreciate that sir thank you and
and uh I guess I would ask if there was
any ability for this uh subcommittee to
recommend to the committee
to maybe just allow us some time to uh
you know really work on this from uh
from the stakeholders point of view
right
and and really uh dig deep on you know
how much is this pinching recruitment
and retention
how difficult is this for uh these
smaller agencies to retain folks is
there a better test that would be more
strongly embraced by the rank and file
or whether it really needs to go away
you know and and that and that's that's
on the table we don't take that off the
table that that could be a viable option
here that ultimately we decide on but if
there was any way we could get more time
I think that would be helpful
representative Stone
this to me is a very important question
how we proceed is really what is your
I I think that uh certainly if we were
given until the next legislative cycle
that we we certainly would be able to uh
it is my opinion that
we would be more ready and when I say we
collectively I'm speaking maybe out of
out of school here but I think the law
enforcement Community would probably be
able to give more definitive positions
once this is kind of Knocked around a
little bit if that helps sir it does I'm
not going to hold you to the time frames
but this is a big undertaking I believe
20 years ago there was discussion about
different standards that could be
implemented for more job specific and
gender neutral even back then before
General was really a term
but I can appreciate your your honesty
as far as your bandwidth goes because it
is a huge undertaking to try to change
and I understand that thank you thank
you sir
any other questions on the committee
well it looks like it's crunch time
we're gonna
one last call is there anyone that would
wish to come and speak
okay
so we have a couple uh as representative
Muse said we have some options here um
after reading a reading listening to
director skippa
I think I've changed my position on this
uh there still will be the physical
fitness requirements uh but we're
removing the regulatory aspect which I
think is a burden on
police standards local apartments even
on officers I don't think that if we
ought to pass this that officers are
going to be getting out of shape and you
know injuring themselves I just think
that this takes it out of
our hands and gives it to people who
know better than we do the academy and
the local departments I think that this
will help with retention uh so I I'm
going with ought to pass representative
Stone
I'll make the Motion Auto pass
do we have a second
uh chair votes yes on ought to pass
representative Manion yes Representative
gathright no representative Muse
ought to pass three to two
and we will send the report up to uh of
the full committee
I'd like to thank everyone and
representative for presenting your bill
uh we should be hearing this on Friday
from the full committee I believe
so I'd like to thank everyone and I will
close uh the subcommittee on House Bill
113.
and the committee uh take a five-minute
I think that was ridiculous because it
should have been we should have held it
we should have retained it
yeah
realistically
this can be a very very busy Cuts yeah
pushing the time things this is they've
been talking about this for 20 plus
years about trying to come up with more
jobs
afraid are taking it he's taking it but
he claimed that they've gotten a group
together and they did yeah and they
actually said that when they were here
um
um I forget his name from
okay so that five minute break was about
25 minutes my apologies to
representative Manion
at this time I will be opening The
subcommittee Works session on House Bill
305 and I will be calling representative
Tom Manion
all right thank you chair thank you
members of the committee I didn't have a
prepared statement this time because I
want to make sure that whatever
questions you guys got you just fire
them at me I did pass out this uh
handout so it made it a lot clearer what
I was trying to do because I think
before when I just read it to you guys
it didn't really get carry across what I
thought the problem in the existing law
was
so if you read the top bolded part here
it
this this entire section here uh 159 uh
E2 is basically an exception to the
existing uh fire firearm Sanctuary law
that we have so it says you the the just
because they're violating a federal
firearms law does not preclude local law
enforcement from helping the feds if
there's some other crime occurring so in
the case like it would be you know an
assault mass murder whatever it may be
uh the fear of the original Law When It
Was Written uh 159 E1
the fear was that the way it was worded
it could act as a shield if an
individual was only violating a federal
firearms law and then also committing
some other crime that our local law
enforcement couldn't help the feds in at
you know apprehending this person so
there was this big carve output here but
I feel like the the language here is so
incredibly broad it actually nullifies
the intent of the original section that
it's within it says so the the
exclusions include
any violation of New Hampshire law or
any violation of a federal law
regulation order or practice that's
everything under the Sun so you know
jaywalking is covered in this so you
could be you know violating a federal
firearms law and uh because you're
jaywalking at the same time our local
law enforcement can just ignore uh 1591
and render Aid
or support to the federal uh
apprehension of the individual that is
doing nothing more than exercising their
second amendment rights and the FEDS
don't like that so the my language in
the second new just shrinks it down to
where it would actually make sense for
us to aid class a felony which covers
murder uh violent assault uh drug
charges even or even covered by it in uh
sexual crime so if you have any
questions about like what the intent
here is or if there's anything I may
representative Stone
a question of curiosity is why didn't we
do Class B felonies
so the idea here was to cover the more
violent of the crimes because like here
Class B felonies uh a small amount of
illegal substances uh theft of small
property Computer Fraud
things along those lines and it I mean
they don't the feds don't need our help
with something like that there's
nobody's life that's in danger that
requires local law enforcement to help
the feds in their apprehension but under
state laws are there quite a few uh
Class B felonies that are invoked on
crimes against persons
it so the idea here is the class a
felony was to cover the
um violent crime bucket like there's a
lot of things that like to describe
things as violent crime and I from it's
my understanding there's nothing that
just straight up says this is a violent
crime because there was some nebulous
language with that because I remember
there was another bill you guys heard
about
um violent felons per se that would get
their firearms rights back and there was
some contention on what qualifies as a
violent felony whereas class a felony to
meet covered the entire bucket of where
it would be an emergency situation that
would require local law enforcement to
also Aid the feds in whatever was
happening anything else should be
covered the feds can more than handle it
on their own
thank you thanks
as I understand this representative
Manion that this was from House Bill
1178 that's correct okay that was the
original Law this was signed into law
with the the change to the laws you
proposed it cover
um the ability of the state and federal
government to cooperate uh investigating
uh somebody who is making illegal straw
currently no
this straw purchases
do you have representative man
thank you and I'm just trying to
understand I wasn't a part of this when
let's say the federal government is
conducting an operation uh it's related
to gun rights uh we don't get involved
in it however there's a Class B felon
that they discover and and form the
local police about
the local police don't address it at
that point
um but down the road maybe they conduct
an investigation on that beef felony is
that
precluded from this as well I mean no if
there's some other crime they can still
investigate the crime the protection
here is against specifically cooperating
with the feds against violations of your
uh natural right to bear arms so it
would be like in the moment whatever it
may be if there's if there's other
crimes come to light other crime crimes
come to light
thank you
I just want to representative Stone yeah
just speaking on the store purchases
that's usually enforced by federal
agencies
as a primary item of enforcement
not as like a secondary that's normally
the ATF that handles that yes
uh representative Tom Union could you
give like a real world example as to the
current law versus your proposal right
so they it was something similar to what
I was just describing let's say I uh
just so happened to let's say an assault
weapons ban comes down the pipe and uh
I want to buy it anyway in New Hampshire
and we pass a law that just ignores it
and I purchase a
you know assault what they Define as an
assault weapon but then I also happen to
have
um a small amount of cannabis in my
pocket uh the under the current law
local law enforcement would see that oh
well your violating a federal law uh the
d The Drug Enforcement Act and uh and
you're also violating this gun law we
can't enforce the gun law but because
you got that weed in your pocket we can
help the feds detain you
okay so you're just you're really trying
to remove the oversight of the feds onto
the local Army yeah more or less the
idea here is uh
I'm trying to use good language uh
trying to not be the federal
government's Whipping Boy or so to say
or to to be at their beck and call to
enforce laws that we don't believe in in
this state that we should not believe in
in this state uh should not be something
that the law enforcement should be
tasked to do I think it's a waste of
resources I think it's a trains our
police in a bad uh way of thinking uh
representative guthright
so
then what's happening
the local police can't do anything
for for if there's so the idea here is
the entire law protects against a a
federal gun whatever it may be like an
apprehension a raid whatever it is
if a class a felony is occurring at the
same time that's that could the local
and state could help right but right now
the way the law is written right now it
doesn't have to be it could be any it
literally says a violation of a federal
law regulation order or practice that's
all kinds of stuff if you dig deep
enough you're breaking a law right now
if you dig deep enough through uh all
the federal bureaucracy and every single
regulation that exists so the S
follow-up yes so the essence of it if
let's say it's a felony B then that
means that the police department cannot
act not for yes not in the enforcement
of a federal gun gun law by the ATF or
whatever it may be yeah sorry I know
that this is yeah I tried to make it
like this is the simplest I thought this
was such a simple Bill all into is
shrinking it down because if you read
this first paragraph I don't know how
you can see that this isn't like a
humongous loophole and basically it
provides no protection it completely
guts the original Law the intent and I'm
sure whoever wrote it that wasn't their
intention I'm sure there was more uh
well we want to make sure that if the
guys uh you know a mass shooter that he
should the that the feds were trying to
apprehend that our local law enforcement
can of course go and help
yeah I was here for that and um I I
think what happened was in order to get
that bill through that's the what was
written The Way It Was Written I've
heard I've heard that same exact story
yeah the A.G I think said that he was
going to advise the governor to not sign
the law unless there was some kind of uh
exclusion to because there's other
components in here that there are
there's other rsas that we have to
enforce with the feds regardless and
they wanted to make sure that all of
that was covered I just think that this
one specific sentence was just overly
Broad and it really defeats the purpose
of the entire section whether that was
intentionally or intentional or not they
wanted it to be like a uh paying lip
service to uh gun rights and not
actually be gun rights I guess that's
we'll see if this bill passes or not or
gets signed
and to follow up with uh representative
gaththright I did speak with Senator
Abbas about this who is one of the ones
who crafted it he said that again they
fought tooth and nail to get where they
got and I I do appreciate this
clarification of the wordage yeah uh
because
the federal government has a lot of
resources they can do their own job
State local County or a small state we
should be focusing on our own so I
understand how you're trying to really
show this all up I just don't know if
how hard fought it was last year that
this will go through but that's
something we're gonna have to see on the
on the board yeah how we're going to
vote yeah and like this whole thing
comes up like if you look I mentioned it
in the hearing before there's a Twitter
account called like crime a day and they
just said that like if they tweet a a
federal crime that you could commit
every day it would it would be like the
heat death of the universe before they
managed to tweet one a day but like of
all the crimes you could potentially be
breaking any regulation which is what
this would be we've seen a lot of the
the gun bills I know representative
Manny you testified on some of those
that they change the laws as they wish
if whatever way the wind blows and it's
I mean representative Stone could attest
to this and that that's just gun laws
this is literally it says any regulation
it doesn't have to be ATF it could be
the you know EPA regulation it could be
uh Department of Agriculture regulation
if your your seeds are doing the wrong
thing whatever it may be you know they
yeah just a just a question if if a
crime violates
both state and federal law
wouldn't a small state that
doesn't have adequate police resources
the way that it stands now want to turn
down help from the federal government if
it's also a violation it's the other way
around of our law right this is the
other way around it would be the feds
are already enforcing a gun gun law that
is on their books and the original Law
here prohibits our law enforcement from
aiding them in that process so it's like
it's the opposite of what you're
describing and that's why I have a
problem with it because they're in the
feds if they want to enforce their dumb
laws they should do it on their dime and
not be tasking our law enforcement to
help them enforce whatever whims they
representative Stone thank you just for
uh clarification for the subcommittee uh
in the state of New Hampshire that no
there is no NFA laws which is uh
National firearm Act laws which are
referred to as class threes New
Hampshire doesn't have any laws on the
books from relevance to NFA laws however
the federal government has a sole
purpose of enacting by either uh
Congressional or by rulemaking Authority
through the ATF such as an example would
be the pistol race law that just came
down there was it's a lot it's a law but
it's really a ruling that the ATF has
redefined and I think this is the type
of example that could be best suited
since our attorney general's already
signed on with 24 other states to fight
this one yeah
I just want to carry on there's one
other thing that was on their website
for a short stint of time there was a
law that says if you had an NFA item uh
you could not even let someone borrow it
unless they were registered with it that
was on their website that wasn't that
didn't even go through the rulemaking
process that was just something they
threw on a website and who knows what
that whether they'd enforce it or not
it's impossible to know representative
Stone so basically you're taking the
same position that this would avoid any
uh rule-making Authority or executive
orders that lack due process absolutely
yes that's the entire purpose of this
yep
any other questions
represent Mania thank you for coming to
clarify I know it was uh everyone was
kind of a little confused and I know you
explained the bill to me prior to and I
want to to have you come up to really
explain it in a better way because I
know that you have some really good uh a
good bill here uh cool
so I guess we're
also did we have a motion
yeah my motion to it out the bill
second
no
representative gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Stone no
and representative
tens are as a no
represents Stone motion to Auto pass
do I have a second representative tensor
seconds
representative Dennis Manu
yes
representative gathright no
representative muse no representative
Stone yes and the chair votes yes and by
three to two ought to pass
to the committee I think this one is in
March
at this time close the subcommittee work
session on House Bill
305.
so it being 104 I'm going to officially
reopen this subcommittee work session on
HP 107.
and uh there's some discussion on we
have an amendment that's been sent to us
uh that representative verbill and Lynn
worked on together
um I don't know who's had an opportunity
to review it yet but some discussion
representative Muse
um just quickly I think that the
amendment makes the bill better than the
one that we passed last year that didn't
get through the Senate so so there's
there's that the the other thing and
this is something that uh representative
Lynn just pointed out to me in a quick
hallway conversation is that the the
last two Clauses are pretty duplicative
there's nothing in so there's nothing in
the the last part of the change that
actually is really anything different
from before
um it's more more of a wordsmithing
thing uh it's not anything that
materially would affect the bill one way
or another
so and I think the issue is if you look
kind of down at line 19
.
you know that involves direct
supervision of minors or that involves
one-on-one work with minors or any
employment or volunteer service that
involves the direct supervision of
minors so we're kind of hammering that
direct supervision of miners uh thing in
in a couple of times
um when it might be only necessary for
uh to do it once but um the question is
is does it materially change anything
and the way the bill would be enforced
I think what I think the reason why it's
it's duplicated is because of the two
separate
um
employment categories employment of
volunteer activity that provides
services exclusively or predominantly to
minors and then any employment of
volunteer services that involves direct
supervision of minus so
the work in a place that provides a
service to miners
or whether your job requires you to be a
direct supervisor to a minor so I think
the reason why it looks like it's
duplicative is that it's two separate
categories of employment okay one being
so so you're saying one is if you run a
daycare one is if you work at Market
Basket basically
so if you work at Market Basket and you
are working with an employee one-on-one
or you're a direct supervisor to a minor
it would apply otherwise it wouldn't if
you're in the dairy department and
you're working doing your shelves and a
kid walks up for directions like we
explained last time it doesn't apply to
that but if your job is you're going to
be left one-on-one with a minor in the
freezer of the dairy section that can't
happen if you're going to be assigned as
someone's supervisor and they're a minor
that can't happen however you could
still work at Market Basket that's how I
understood this change to be
but I think it was done that way for
that for that Landscaping thing where
the boss leaves the kid with the sex
offender and he's now supervising that
sex offender and he's also one-on-one
with him so I think it covers it in both
both Avenues the only other comment I
would have is if you if if you notice
that um we had a section one is actually
one continuous sentence so I think we
may have we may be uh setting a new
record for the longest sentence uh in
any New Hampshire RSA so
but I think as long as it is clear and I
think that's you know
maybe
um
we we do have a representative of uh of
law enforcement who I think has a copy
of the amendment
could you give us I want to mention also
that when yes please
I think it's worth noting also that when
courts look at the rsas they look at our
discussion and the any recordings of our
discussion so that will help
yes
okay and I I apologize sorry I didn't
hear your question or
the concern the question would be is as
you read you know as you read it the way
that it's the one thing that does
concern me with long sentences is
someone who's a fan of plain language
um is do you think anybody will have any
trouble interpreting the statute or do
you think that there's potential for
misinterpretation of it or so
I think that excuse me by clearing up
what exactly they can and can't do I
mean this is a pretty good guideline for
you know School administrator guidance
counselor coach
um you know I think that outlines
everything
um
one of the one of the concerns I have
and I think I talked about it a little
bit last week and uh certainly the
paralegal in the office wanted me to
is this just for
so again we have a certain amount of
offenders who have not offended against
and based on the research from Bradley I
think it is in fact it's everyone and it
always has been and my misunderstanding
yeah I don't think the law on that is
changing so the existing Law whatever
that covers this is still covering we're
just changing the definition to close
that loophole for that landscaper
situation so I think if and that could
be wrong
that that part of the law already exists
that it includes everybody and that's
not changing well the the part of the
law that doesn't change says a person is
guilty if having been convicted of this
or any other jurisdiction
in this or any other jurisdiction of any
felonious offense involving child sexual
abuse images or if a felonious physical
assault on a minor or of any sexual
assault he or she blah blah blah and
then
um and then there's a section two
that's or sorry section yeah section two
a person is guilty if
um having been convicted in this or any
other jurisdiction of any of the
offenses specified in paragraph one and
then a person is guilty if haven't been
convicted on this or any other
jurisdiction
of any of the offenses specified in
paragraph one so it's just I guess it
all goes back to paragraph one and
that's unchanged okay from prior law so
the only thing that I would say
is that if we are going according to
paragraph one
uh if um
convicted in this jurisdiction or any
other jurisdiction of any felonious
offense involving child sexual abuse
images
felonious physical assault on a minor or
any sexual assault
as law enforcement
if I have somebody that is a sex
offender that's committed a crime other
than this
in my opinion it looks like this doesn't
apply so take for example
we have a a large amount of offenders
who are convicted under RSA 649 B4 use
of certain Computer Services prohibited
these are the offenders
online
luring children to meet with them
talking with law enforcement uh you know
when they think they're 13 year old boys
and girls
they could still be convicted of that
because it doesn't specifically say that
and I think that's going to be in my
opinion would be a loophole because I
mean I think it's
um written broadly
so that law enforcement can interpret it
and apply it without having the
construction of specificity
but it does say involving child sexual
abuse images so I feel like that's
really broad there and would cover that
but but anyway the the wording that
wording is not changing so however it's
been enforced in the past would continue
to be enforced the same way it's just
that now the things that they can't work
at are more
are covered better and I certainly see
that my
my concern would be
that if if I'm a 47 year old male
talking with a 13 year old female trying
to lure her I don't send her pictures
but we're having a conversation back and
forth hey meet me at
you know Chipotle it's afternoon three
o'clock so we can have a conversation
that involves a sexual conversation
when really they're conversing with a
police officer I think
a defense attorney would be able if if
this would apply to them
and they were rejected of employment for
one of these things I think that
a skilled lawyer would be able to go
back and say Hey look
he didn't send any images he hasn't been
convicted of any sexual assault
but he's convicted of use of certain
Computer Services
I think he's going to fall in these
parameters and again I'm not I don't
want to throw too much of a monkey
wrench into this for you but looking at
it as a law enforcement capacity I think
that um
I think that that moving forward could
be a concern those um we have
uh probably I'm going to go out on a
limb here and say
a good amount of our offenders are
convicted of this crime
doesn't fit into they have an assaulted
anybody
it's not a sexual assault they haven't
but they're still convicted of a sex
offender crime all right I don't I don't
disagree with that but that's not the
bill that was presented to us that's
current language okay so I guess and I
don't know if that's something we would
address here in this committee to change
it again the current law the bill
proposed to us and that's how it's been
as representative Bolin said that's how
it's been enforced since this since its
Inception okay this bill is is is
basically just changing the language
identifying what employment you cannot
have
enclosing that loophole so that that
current languages have a lot is today
okay
so I don't know if this is the place
where we're going to address that part
of it
I mean if we're going to talk about
um including a whole new group of people
in this law I think that's really a
situation deserving of a public hearing
and its own legislation because it's
pretty complex and I wouldn't I know
that if it was going to affect my life I
wouldn't want for technically four folks
in a subcommittee to be making that
decision on a day when I told security I
wouldn't be parked on Park Street Long
yes
um I agree and I appreciate I appreciate
the clarification kind of bringing that
out but of course I I think that that
would be better for another bill and
would like to uh support that bill
yeah and I don't disagree with you right
now I look at that and I interpret that
how you're interpreting it sure that
there's a loophole there but we have to
I think we're kind of in a position here
where we're going to address the bill as
presented to us with the changes they're
looking to make and it might be a bill
down the road that we could uh sponsor
put together to this does clarify yeah
this does clarify a lot of the questions
we had is this um something that would
be and you may or may not know this but
retroactive if somebody's employed in a
perfect I would imagine it is so
retroactive there's nothing about this
that suggests that
um unless you already had the employment
before such and such date and I think
that's the point of the long effective
date is to give people
um who are employed sorry people who are
offenders under this law the opportunity
to be contacted by I assume your agency
or something to notify them of the
changes in law around their employment
I would agree with that as well okay
this kind of defeats the purpose if it's
not retroactive if you have a job
currently that you're violating and you
do you keep it for 10 years because
you're grandfathered in and
so I agree with that
no
no also I think it's worth noting that
the sponsor said his goal was to close
the loophole and I think we've
accomplished that with the wording and
you know you're always free to approach
any lawmakers particularly on this
committee with um your proposal you know
we can file bills and like um I want to
I do have a question about the we took
the background check out of this
build so that isn't part of the law
however and correct me if I'm wrong
there are Provisions in place already
because I know that I and uh just a
little bit about my experience I've been
in law enforcement for 30 years and I
know that I've done fingerprint
applications for school teachers in town
uh for their employment so there are
teachers and councils that have to get
fingerprinted do you do you know what
that provision is is it a separate law
is it is it administrative
sorry I wish I knew I I honestly I don't
I'm sure there's something in place I I
just I don't know all right thank you
and I think that that question about
this that being part of the law would
overburden not only the state with
background checks but also
employers if it would you know they
would have to conduct these background
checks if they want to hire five people
that could take months before they get
one in the door so but that's been
removed okay uh so it's it's basically
back to the original Law
with the expanded definition of what
kind of employment you can have that
close to loopholes which are definitely
it definitely adds quite a bit
are there any more questions of uh this
I agree
I think you know moving forward it my
office is uh
you know we do a lot of work in there we
work a lot of different agencies I get
multiple calls a day on enforcement
issues and I just uh
I see that being the one you know a
couple of people picked up on it right
off the bat and said well wait a minute
there's gonna be a problem and that's
the current law so it is correct you're
right but it is but
yeah okay I would be interested to know
you know in the time period that we have
between today and when legislators can
file more legislation if you do end up
reaching out to a rep and asking them to
file something I think this committee
would want to know if there are people
um who are on the registry who do work
potentially in the capacity described in
this legislation
um that are that were permitted to under
the
um sorry not under this legislation I'd
be interested to know if there are
people who
are convicted uh sex offenders who don't
meet the description in the existing law
pre these changes who have been working
um in positions that you know
um are described in the existing law so
like are there people with a computer
activities whatever conviction that
maybe you're aware of their employment
and it does involve children and then
additionally
um would be interested to know if there
are any other
descriptors or convictions that you
think should be included and also
um
um I think maybe that's it just just an
FYI for when you're you know because
we're gonna want to know those I imagine
if there's a bill like that it would be
it would be
I'm not sure how we would do it when
when we take registrations from
offenders we obviously have them
um tell us you know where they work all
online identifiers employment anything
that changes with them they're required
by law to come in and let us know that
there's been a status update new job
things like that but occasionally take
phone calls for example we took a phone
call last week
about three weeks ago notifying of us
and I won't say which restaurant but a
fairly large chain restaurant relocated
a female offender from Florida to New
Hampshire to be the
um general manager of a restaurant where
she's going to supervise obviously
everybody
you know in looking into it a lot of the
hostesses and hosts are you know 16 17
years old so
I'm not
you know siding with one person or
another but that's that's gonna
end her career with that restaurant and
obviously people make decisions early on
in life and you know that's what she's
got to live with but these are the
things that I'm sure my office is going
to get phone calls if if and when this
passes Hey listen this is my situation I
just got terminated according to the law
so these are the things that and I don't
know her specific story I just know
that that happened so
um to your point I don't know I could it
would be tough to put together a
spreadsheet to say hey we have
you know out of the 3000 offenders we
have
300 of them that were supervising
children and
and then we would have to look and see
okay what were their offenses you know
are there a registered sex offender yes
they are but maybe it was uh
something not outlined here or something
different so these are things we would
have to put together and
not sure we would have the staffer
you know to be able to do that I don't
know if that answers your question but
yeah I think if you can tell us like we
know that roughly this many people are
potentially involved in supervisory
positions but we have no idea at any
given point who their co-workers are
um that would be at least helpful and
apparently um RSA 170-e colon 4
um maybe that's the wrong one the
background checks are required for
daycare providers already
yes
right I don't know
um
fully
so one other question and I'll leave you
would there be some Provisions uh in
this law that I just don't see for
example
um
so if you have an offender
that works
in the Food Service somewhere
who doesn't supervise miners
and the supervisor that day calls in
sick so this soup this offender
is now training
new hires and is their supervisor for
that day I know that's a stretch but it
happens so does that
do they fit into one of these categories
I don't think I think I don't think it
is a stretch I think that the the way
that the bill is written it would
require an employee to be open with
their employer and communicative to make
sure that if that employer wants to
employ a sex offender that they're
cautious about what they direct them to
do and I would want that you know yeah I
think and just the supervising that
person they're also one-on-one with that
person potentially which which is
another section of this so I think
that's the loophole that we're looking
to
close and it's on that person to notify
the employer I think like you know in my
job I you know I work as a homeless
Advocate which means that I'm kind of
the one person who's directly
supervising in you know being in the
office and
um and it's mostly single moms and so my
dad who is the executive director of the
shelter still won't be there for an
overnight shift or be the person who's
there because just inherently because
he's a man and he cannot be in
situations like that where there could
be any type of liability or anything
like that best guy assault of the Earth
but he still you know can't be in that
position in the same way when you're
hiring uh somebody knowing that they're
in the situation you provide for that
okay
thank you all right thank you I found
the Senate blurb the committee report
from 2022
I Can't Believe It's Not 2022 anymore
um and it just said
although the issue is worthy of
consideration the language is in need of
further review before it can be
implemented so I mean we did that
so do we vote I don't remember how
subcommittee works anymore
I think we do I think so we someone will
make a motion to adopt this amendment
and if it's a DOT adopted maybe we make
a motion to whether we OTP or ideal it
or as our recommendation to the
committee
I think and I don't know if
representative news is wordsmithing some
more it looks like you might be trying
yeah
I'm just looking to see if there was any
kind of an interim study report okay
usually I can find them if there are if
they're there but I couldn't find one
here
so um and that's that's one of the
issues when we refer stuff to interim
study sometimes things get studied
sometimes they're they're not really
prioritized for study and they fall off
the map and it's hard to know what
happened so they were never actually
studied they were just set up for study
okay with that in mind though I will uh
move uh Amendment
2023-05 86 H
um
uh with a recommendation of ought to
pass on HB 107 FN
all right I guess we'll take a vote and
uh
I am a yes representative Muse
yes representative Newell yes and
representative bouldin
aye
and I'm new to this too so that I
apparently there's a form that I didn't
have last time that I'm filling out now
um
and I guess just a
maybe it's a point of order here so once
we've adopted these this amendment or
have we already do we need to vote
further to recommend the committee or is
that suffice what we've done technically
technically amendments don't require
formal votes or roll call votes even in
full Committee in a regular exact
session they can be agreed to by a Voice
vote informally and they and the
agreement doesn't even need to be
recorded until you record the final
notion of Ops as amended so the fact
that we all agree to it and then did a
Voice vote I think is and then of course
representative Muse said ought to pass
in his motion okay so I think that there
are separate sections on here that's why
I'm wondering we've I think we've
completed the voting process
if we were recommending if we were going
to recommend itl we wouldn't even have
them take up the amendment in in the
committee
all right so I've
we are finished here uh I guess we'll
adjourn this meeting unless anyone has
anything else
that's it thank you
we'll close the uh subcommittee session